Lurigancho jail is one of South
America's toughest prisons conditions
are appalling
dude largely to overcrowding built for
3,600 in now houses nearly 10,000
inmates in Peru officially we assumed
the criminals had a second chance and
they have to be rehabilitated but
unfortunately the reality it's not
normally like that because we don't have
enough phones we don't have enough money
on budget we have mass overcrowding
Lurigancho
21 overcrowded cell blocks can explode
into open civil war in 1986 in one day
alone a hundred and twenty four
prisoners died the authorities only have
100 guards to please 10,000 violent
inmates it has led to an extraordinary
deal the Peruvian Prison Service has
handed power to the inmates this is very
difficult for 100 people to control
10,000 emails so they have normally do
to ask for the support of criminals who
are leaders in the prison and normally
these people helps a lot to get calmed
the prison guards patrol the walls and
control the entrances to the blocks but
it's the prisoners who run the jail
day-to-day there is a ruling council of
inmate leaders called the delegates they
are elected by the inmates but often
they are the most powerful criminals in
the jail people that have Condon's of 20
years 15 years that have been very well
known criminals and now what they only
want is the quota power you know so they
help the authorities to have to come the
new criminals they're a major tourism
because as a disciplinary Lotito and
those who takes on the legal is the most
control in Pinal I pass for the last
three years they have kept a fragile
peace but the prison remains on a
knife-edge